oi oi gente eu sou a Verônica Hipólito
tenho 24 anos graduanda da usb-c e
atleta paralímpica eu sou campeão
mundial Tenho 7 medalhas pan-americanas
duas medalhas paraolímpicas uma de prata
e outra de bronze e para resumir bem
todas as minhas conquistas eu sou uma
das oito mulheres mais rápidas do mundo
de todos os tempos o paralímpico eu tava
pensando aqui começa ia começar a falar
com vocês Será que eu fazia uma piada
uma introdução breve Mas então eu decidi
começar com as minhas medalhas porque aí
quem sabe vocês não me dão moral né
mesmo e vocês acreditam que com todos
o títulos as pessoas ainda dizem que
isso é porque eu era o meu destino ou
algo ou alguém escolheu o qualquer
justificativa para dizer que o que eu
conquistei e onde eu estou hoje já era
para tá aqui já era para acontecer
independentemente das pedras no caminho
mas para falar bem a real eu não
acredito nessa coisa de certas pessoas
especiais que são escolhidas para serem
mais especiais o que eu acredito de
verdade é em trabalho duro em Criar e
aproveitar a janela de oportunidades aí
você se arriscar e sair da zona de
conforto que aliás essa tal de zona de
conforto é um lugar maravilhoso só não
se sente dor medo frustração raiva lugar
lindo maravilhoso mas também você fica
estagnado para sempre lá se vive o
eterno em cima e se eu tivesse tentado E
se eu tivesse feito em seu por
Oi e a eterna dúvida Isso deve ser uma
das piores coisas que se possa carregar
na vida mas enfim eu acho que agora é
meia hora de compra argumentar o motivo
de eu não acreditar nessa coisa de
destino E para isso eu tenho que voltar
ao lado início da história eu sempre fiz
parte do esporte isso porque meu pai e
minha mãe eles sempre acreditaram que
educação Esporte sempre caminhavam lado
a lado que com eles a gente poderia
formar ajudava a formar o caráter que
também trazem experiências e te ensinava
coisas que provavelmente você não
conseguiria aprender só na teoria e por
isso eu participei de várias modalidades
esportivas futebol futsal tênis de mesa
tênis de Campo ginastica judô karatê
natação e todas as modalidades que vocês
puderem pensar o que não significa assim
né que eu era uma esperança uma promessa
do esporte brasileiro
Boa tarde na natação a minha mãe chegou
agora uma competição achando que eu tava
me afogando mas na verdade eu tava
nadando tá galera no tênis de mesa era
melhor em cartaz bolinhas no chão no
futebol e no futsal Sim eu me tornei a
melhor goleira eu não sei como Até hoje
me lembro que a bola sempre vinha parar
na minha cabeça na minha barriga não tem
explicação mas só ir no judô que eu me
encontrei foi lá que meus olhos
brilharam pela primeira vez e eu sabia
que era lá que eu queria promolimp aí
comecei a escutar sobre os jogos mais
disputados e que todos os atletas
queriam as Olimpíadas e paralimpíadas só
que tinha um problema que eu era
pequenininha demais para quem é demais
magrinha demais na minha turma só tinha
um homens acima de 110 120 kg então em
qualquer treino que eu ia eu já me
machucava tudo para dar errado
é mas foi nessa época que eu aprendi
sobre uma coisa que eu nem sabia que
existia resiliência é a capacidade de se
adaptar às más condições nas minhas
palavras e na prática é a vida ao mundo
bater bater bater bater em você e você
se levantar porque você tem um sonho
porque você tem uma meta porque tem algo
que faça os seus olhos brilharem então
resolvido ao meu Melhor dois anos depois
vou entrar no judô em 2009 quando eu
tinha 12 para 13 anos eu comecei a ficar
mais forte Então foi do Municipal
Estadual para o estadual do interior e
aí eu conquistei a tão sonhada vaga por
Nacional
é só que eu não fui para o Nacional
há algumas semanas antes eu tive que
fazer exame de rotina E aí o médico
passou para outro que passou para outro
que passou para outro até chegar no
neurocirurgião e lá ele disse que eu
tinha um tumor na cabeça que precisava
ser operado com urgência aquele momento
eu me vi diante um problema e aprendi
sobre a questão problema é solução o meu
problema era um tumor na cabeça mas eu
tinha solução que era poder operar e
minha mãe disse na época que eu tinha
que fazer o que deveria ser feito
bom então eu operei
é só que após a cirurgia eu descobri que
eu não conseguiria voltar para o
Nacional do judô Eu não conseguiria nem
voltar para te ajudou ou qualquer outra
modalidade esportiva que fosse de lutas
o que tivesse bola qualquer tipo de tipo
de impacto e no mundo caiu naquele
momento porque tinha aqui o que fazia
meus olhos brilharem e de repente sumiu
o meu pai me vendo como eu tava triste
ele escreveu no festival de atletismo e
claro que não queria ir o primeiro
motivo é que era no domingo entre 78
horas da manhã e eu duvido que alguém
aqui queria sair no domingo em 17 8
horas da manhã e eu segundo é porque era
preciso não tinha graça não tinha gosto
para mim só que no dia meu pai e minha
mãe me levaram
e já que era para eu ir numa Competição
eu não aceitava menos o que ganhar só
que na hora aconteceu o contrário se
tivesse um lugar depois do último
provavelmente era lá que eu ficaria da
surra que eu levei das outras meninas
mas eu tive uma certeza naquele momento
eu queria ser a menina mais rápida da
cidade então logo eu comecei a treinar
Atletismo só que era vivência então era
aquela coisa mais de brincadeira onde o
treinador não se importava se você
completar seu treino não tinha problema
do que você comia não tinha problema de
você faltar e eu queria mais então
perguntei para ele quando eu poderia
entrar no alto rendimento treinar de
verdade sonhar de verdade e se a menina
mais rápida da cidade fazer isso
acontecer Ele disse que seria no
seguinte quando eu fizesse meus 15 anos
em junho de 2011
é só que março eu senti um formigamento
é como se nosso braço ou perna tiver
formigando mesmo só quero uma faixa
passando por mim e é por onde essa faixa
postava eu parava de sentir eu não
conseguia mais mover era de noite e eu
me lembro que eu tentei falar para o meu
irmão mas eu não conseguia mais falar a
faixa de formigamento chegou no meu
quadril e eu só lembro de cair no chão
é a última coisa que me lembro era
ligando para os meus pais e depois disso
eu acordei no hospital
e lá me falaram que eu tinha tido um AVC
e que eu tava com lado direito inteiro
paralisado eu me lembro poucas coisas
depois disso mas algumas ficaram uma
Caldas Como olhar de pena das pessoas
para mim o que infelizmente já é normal
para pessoas que tem algum tipo de
deficiência e outra coisa que me marcou
era palavra das pessoas você quer voltar
a correr impossível você não vai me
botar andar só que para os meus pais não
a minha mãe disse que em todo tudo que
eu pudesse todos os dias eu desse meu
melhor que eu não aceitasse ficar na
média só fazer e pronto desce o meu
melhor sempre e o meu pai na porta do
hospital ele falou que quando a gente
saísse todo mundo ia tentar militar
dizer o que é possível ou impossível
para mim e eu deveria decidir o que eu
ia fazer
e naquele momento eu tive a certeza de
uma coisa que só eu e a dizer o que
seria impossível para mim eu decidi que
nada seria se eu me esforçasse
trabalhasse duro foi então que eu voltei
para fisioterapia para fonoaudiologia
voltei a falar depois andei trotei corri
corri mais rápido nunca mais parei só
que eu queria ser menina mais rápida da
cidade então procurei a melhor equipe
naquele momento fiz um teste para entrar
passei de raspão mas eu passei só que
tinha algo que ainda me incomodava por
mais que eu treinasse do que os outros
atletas eu continuava mancando eu tinha
espasmos e meu braço continuava tenso
como se tivesse rígido e o treinador na
época que era especialista em Olímpico e
paralímpico disse que isso provavelmente
era porque eu era um atleta paralímpica
que todo esse tempo Tava competindo com
atletas olímpicos o que eu tinha era uma
sequela de AVC
a e foi então que em 2013 quando eu
tinha uns 16 anos eu fiz uma
classificação com pessoas capacitados
para saber se eu tinha legibilidade ou
não para entrar no movimento e eu passei
a minha primeira competição foi o
campeonato regional Só que lá muita
gente disse Regional são os melhores da
região Verônica vai ser impossível você
conseguir algo você já voltando ó tá
excelente só que eu queria mais então o
que vocês três medalhas de ouro e
Internacional depois do Nacional As
Pessoas Mais uma vez Verônica você já
virou melhor da região tá tudo bem Você
já fez o bastante é impossível vocês é
uma das melhores do Brasil mais uma vez
mais três ouros e o índice para uma
outra competição essa competição seja a
última chance dos atletas fazer um
índice para o mundial adulto se lá você
já sabe né
e é impossível Verônica você já fez
bastante mas eu queria mais e foi então
que aos 17 anos eu conquistei um link
para o campeonato mundial Só que lá eu
comecei a ficar com um pouco de medo é
uma os melhores do mundo e se eu
perdesse eu ia dar argumento para
aquelas pessoas tá dizendo que se
realmente sem possível conseguir algo e
se eu fosse desclassificada eu sairia
antes da ordem de largada antes dela
dentro de correr e aí eu não ia ganhar
mas eu não ia perder
e quando chegou perto da hora da prova
eu lembrei que eu tava fazendo era um
absurdo que eu tava me impossibilitando
que eu ia correr e eu tinha corrido
várias outras vezes era só me divertir e
foi isso que aconteceu eu corri e eu me
divertir e foi assim que aos 17 anos
estreante no campeonato mundial eu me
tornei campeão mundial recordista
mundial aquele momento eu já não era só
a menina mais rápida da cidade eu era a
mulher mais rápida do mundo e eu queria
mais Em 2014 eu ganhei tudo pela frente
não perdi nenhuma competição bate todos
os recordes em 2015 Eu já queria mais
faltava um ano para os jogos
paralímpicos e olímpicos a competição
mais desejada por todos os atletas só
que eu comecei a me sentir um pouco
fraca e com mais sono e meu rendimento
só ia caindo então fiz outro exame
Oi e aí eu descobri aqui eu tava com
ferro baixo porque eu tava sangrando
muito esse sangue vinha do intestino
grosso e isso era porque eu tinha mais
de 200 tumores l
e às vésperas do Campeonato Panamericano
sa às vésperas do mundial e faltando
menos de um ano para os jogos
paralímpicos do rio-2016 parecia que eu
ia perder tudo novamente problema
solução eu tinha um problema que eram os
mais de 200 tumores eu tinha solução que
ela cirurgia por mais que fosse
arriscada Mas eu sabia o que eu queria
eu sabia que o certo era a confiar e
acreditar na ciência e foi o que
aconteceu mais uma vez dor medo e
segurança eu resolvi sair da zona de
conforto mas eu decidi dar o meu melhor
então eu voltei a correr depois eu
conseguiu o índice para os jogos
paralímpicos e aí então e setembro de
2016 eu tava lá na maior e mais desejada
a competição por todos os atletas do
mundo
e as paralimpíadas do Rio 2016 foi lá
que eu conquistei uma medalha de prata e
uma medalha de bronze bronze que foi o
ouro para mim porque foi nessa prova que
foi batido o recorde europeu asiático
das Américas Hospital CNA o recorde da
competição e recorde mundial um quinto
lugar teria conquistado o recorde
mundial em primeiro lugar e eu queria
mais depois mais ainda eu já pensava em
Tokyo 2020 Farias 2024 Los Angeles 2028
pensava em mais e não ser somente uma
das meninas mais rápidas do mundo mas a
mais rápida fazer histórias em uma
gigante
é mas em 2017 uma volta para minha
cabeça mais uma cirurgia
em 2018 mais uma vez costuma Voltou na
minha cabeça o único caso no mundo e
mais uma cirurgia a minha hipófise é a
glândula mestra dos hormônios parou de
funcionar então eu tive que tomar
corticoide e aí dos 47 kg de repente eu
me vi com mais de 70 kg Idas e Vindas
para o hospital muita dor e o famoso
Será que eu vou conseguir
é mas é o poder dos micro hábitos todo
dia dá um pouquinho melhor de você um
tijolinho a mais na construção
O que foi assim que eu fui voltando
quando eu voltei para os treinos não era
sobre a Verônica voltou mas sim olha o
peso dela Olha a barriga dela era sobre
a minha forma física no início tive
vergonha mas depois eu vi que aquele era
o meu caminho e que eu deveria aprender
no caminho e o máximo possível ensinar
outras pessoas com que eu passasse
e depois disso eu consegui voltar a
competir já não era mais o mundo dizendo
é impossível Verônica metade dele era o
mundo todo não enquanto uma metade dizia
a Verônica não vai voltar é impossível a
outra metade já falava a Verônica sempre
volta
e o que aconteceu depois disso eu deixo
para vocês porque aliás Essa não é uma
história sobre medalhas e recordes e
sobre ser ou não a melhor do mundo essa
é uma história sobre você correr atrás
dos seus sonhos essa é uma história que
não existem pessoas escolhidas existem
pessoas com problemas que resolvem
acreditar na solução
E se eu tivesse ficado na zona de
conforto Se eu tivesse tido medo
provavelmente ela não teria ido atrás do
esporte eu não teria conhecido o valores
como a resiliência coragem e assim eu
poderia ter sido somente a menina dos
mais de 200 tumores o a garota que quase
morreu mas eu decidi essa menina queria
viver eu decidi correr atrás dos meus
sonhos e você é